مع تقدمها اكثر في عمق بخموت تحول القوه
الروسيه مكاسبها الى استعراض للقوه هذه
قوه فاغنر التي تقود الهجوم على المدينه
تبدو اكثر تصميما على اكمال المهمه وفي
الاثناء يجد قادتها متسعا من الوقت
لمكافاه مقاتلهم ومنحهم الاوسمه والنياشين
تعليقا على المعارك هناك قال حاكم
دونيتسكا الموالي لروسيا ان اكثر من 75%
من اراضي باخموت باتت تحت السيطره القوات
الروسيه وان المعارك تدور حاليا غربي
المدينه يقلل الجيش الاوكراني من شان تلك
التصريحات لكنه في الان نفسه يقر بصعوبه
الوضع في بخموت خسائر الروس ضخمه والقوات
الاوكرانيه تعمل على تدمير مواردهم يقول
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني بينما اتهم قائد
القوات البريه الاوكرانيه روسيا باشراك
قوات محموله جوا
وتنفيذ ما سماها تكتيكات الارض المحروقه
بعد ان انهكت قوه فاغنر على حد قوله
مخاوف الاوكرانيين تتخطى ميدان بخموت فقد
حذرت القياده العسكريه الجنوبيه في الجيش
الاوكراني من ان روسيا تدفع بالسفن اضافيه
الى البحر الاسود محمله بصواريخ كاليبر ما
يرجح في اعتقادها احتمال شن هجوم صاروخ
واسع النطاق على مقاطعه اوديسا والمقاطعات
الجنوبيه الاخرى وبينما خافت الحديث عن
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد بسبب التسريبات
في وزاره دفاع الامريكيه التي كشفت جوانب
من خطط الهجوم تتردد في كييف تقارير عن
تعديلات ومراجعات للخطط العسكريه
وتشهد معظم الجبهات تصعيدا عسكريا هذه
الايام فقد استاثرت مقاطعه خرسون بنصيب
وافر من ذلك التصعيد بلغ حد استخدام القوه
الروسيه قنابل موجهه على طول خط الجبهه
وفق المتحدث باسم القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
يستخدم الغزاه القنابل الموجهه على طول خط
الجبهه باكمله وبدات الطائرات الروسيه
باطلاق نحو 20 قنبله بوزن 500 كيلوغرام
يوميا والاعتراض تلك القنابل نحتاج الى
صواريخ مضاده للطائرات وفي مقاطعه
زبولوجيا اعلنت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
سقوط قتلى وجرحى في قصف روسيا على عده
مناطق في المقاطعه ورد الجيش الاوكراني
باستهداف مواقع تمركز الافراد والعتاد
الروسي واسقاط ست طائرات مسيره في المقابل
لا يتوقف القاده العسكريون الروس عن
تصريحتهم اليوميه بتكميد الخصم خسائر
ثقيله في الجنود والعتاد وتدمير منشاه
عسكريه واسقاط مسيرات لكن تلك التطورات
على شدتها لم تمنع الجانبين الروسي
والاوكراني من اجراء عمليه تبادل اخرى
لاسرى الحرب شملت 100 جنديا من كل طرف